Todd McShea from the worldwide leader in
sports college football analyst NFL
draft analyst he joins us here on the
show what what do you say to that answer
that question Todd the fans are pretty
close you know I think with Lamar you
just you look at the the delivery and
the mechanics and you want to see
improvement you want to see not to get
too technical he's kind of a narrow base
thrower kind of comes up over the top
and and can fix that it's not like
changing a quarterbacks complete
delivery but you I think with a little
bit of work he can become more accurate
that's what you want to see there right
I think behind the scenes Josh Rosen
probably has the most work to do and
it's not you know these are just
15-minute interviews with NFL teams and
certainly they have their coordinators
and all to keep people in there and
psychologists in there but if teams are
the teams that are seriously considered
draft during drafting him will obviously
be as Pro day but then we'll go down
bring the decision-makers to him and
spend the day with him throwing and and
working working through some stuff
physically on the field and then they'll
fly him into their facility and my guess
is he's going to have a very busy April
traveling around the country going to
different teams and spending the day
with people and having coaches try to
get to know him and psychologists
spending more time with them trying to
figure out you know the questions that
we've talked about over and over again
with Rosen does he need the game does he
love the game is he coachable and in
figuring out if they have the right
people in place to that he will respect
because he's always going to ask why you
know if you tell him to do something
he's going to say why and it comes off
that's not being coachable sometimes but
I think he wants to know that if he's
doing something that there's a reason
for it and you have to have someone in
place who's capable of dealing with that
yeah of that but I guess the letter
would be W right the kid can win when it
all comes down to it one would think how
much of what happened at UCLA is being
placed placed on his shoulders though
Todd I think ultimately in talking to
people from there and then talking to
Scouts who have talked to more people
ultimately it turned into a situation
where he wasn't always the best teammate
and question authority
wasn't only the most coachable but I
also think he was carrying an entire
program a program that had a lot of
injuries for whatever reason a program
that is where he had three different
coordinators in three different years
and the talent around him was was not
nearly as good as some of the other
places and uh in the pac-12 so I think
you know when you when you look at his
production and what he was able to do 17
and 13 as a starter he played so much
better than a guy who was almost you
know 50 percentage in terms of wins and
losses sixty-one percent of his is you
know attempts were completed it probably
was closer to 70 percent with when you
go back and look at the drops and guys
not getting open and doing what they had
to do and you know I listen there is no
one in this draft that I would rather
ghost play a game tomorrow with and
believe we could win in the NFL than
Rose he is the most NFL ready polished
pure passer of the group but you got to
know what you're getting long-term and
this is a guy that's it's going to
become a Jay Cutler for you or is he
someone that you can manage a little bit
better
Todd McShea here on the Rich Eisen show
and then your colleague our colleague
our buddy Adam Schefter tweet now but
Sam Donald's not going to spin it he'll
put on the whole put on the sweatshirt
well everybody else goes through the
on-field drills how do you think that's
gonna play out for him Todd listen I
want to see them all compete we all do
and I you know hear the narrative every
year but I also am a realist I don't
think a quarterback has ever been
drafted or not drafted off of what he
did or didn't do at the NFL combine I
just I know you're not supposed to say
this I know some guys in the legal
listen to this would be annoyed with me
you know giving him a pass but plenty of
guys have done it before and been very
high picks and gone on to have very good
and it's all careers and I just you know
listen and you're going up we've got
Josh Rosen and Allen and some of the
other really good passers and he has a
unique delivery and to have an apples
apples comparison there maybe that's
what they're trying to avoid I honestly
don't know what the reasoning is but I
could understand it that no one's going
to throw Josh Allen's royal terms of arm
strength
you know Josh Rosen and Baker Mayfield
are very accurate I think he's just as
accurate but they look a little bit more
traditional he's got that longer stroke
and while he gets to know quickly you
know I think I think just having him go
in line you know quarterback after
quarterback after quarterback it's going
to look different than everybody else's
versus if you're just at a pro day or
working him out individually you get
over it a little bit more so if if I had
to guess that might have something to do
with it although maybe he's just chosen
that it's not that big of a deal and
that he'll throw his pro day and he'll
throw for NFL teams and he doesn't need
the program see obviously you know I
have more skin in the game and the fact
that I'm sitting on on a network that's
broadcasting it and uh right so I fully
admit that that my view is viewed
through those glasses okay yeah but
every scout knows going in that his
throw emotions gonna look different
apples you know what I'm saying so it's
it's not as it's not as if it's just Joe
or Jane Schmo just sitting in the stands
watching these guys it's it's viewed
through that way professional so so I
you know what look I I understand that
that that he would be concerned about
not putting his best foot forward
because there could be some you know
division to kid that he's got a throw to
that runs a route in a manner that he's
never seen before but we all know what
it is right I I kind of don't get it and
so if you don't think that there's gonna
be anybody sitting there wondering why
he's not doing it in a in a room what it
push does come to shove if it isn't
obvious to apples he's gonna be asked I
mean every interview he has he'll he'll
have to answer that question and and
I'll be interested to see what the
answer was and how he answered it i it's
it's tough I get it I really honestly do
want to see him compete but this guy was
a high school linebacker didn't play
quarterback really fully until his final
year he played basketball he played
baseball he's all he's done is compete
his entire life he doesn't win the job
and then it gets the job you know two
years ago and in 24 games he goes 20 and
four as a starter so I it's hard for me
if it was a different player it was one
of the other names I would look upon it
a little bit
to be completely transparent with you
then I do with Darnell who is just his
competitive makeup is is one of his
greatest strengths and so I I think this
is more strategic than anything but I I
really don't think it would be something
where you question his his willingness
to compete I really don't at the end of
the day
Todd McShea here on the Rich Eisen show
a couple more minutes with the ESPN
college football analyst and obviously
NFL Draft analysts do you ever do ever
let me in the building brick eyes and
not have secured to keep me out then
maybe I'd be saying yeah let's go dartle
throw well Todd and maybe you should
just stop with the hang in with the
riffraff you know I have no control over
that sort of hang I'm I'm just you know
I'm just the worker bee
when it all comes down to it Todd do you
have right now a draft board but what's
your process right now do you have
players one through all the way down X
right now yeah we're I mean kind of
obligated to its daily you know daily
basis because I mean today for example I
just watch DJ more the wide receiver
from Maryland and like them more than I
thought based on just watching on
television you know so this process is
is a long one and just kind of moving
guys around as you're watching tape but
and so yes it's it's your question I do
there are some players where I feel
really good about cuz I'm done with all
of the the tape work and then there are
other guys that I you know I was getting
the third fourth ground they're guys
that I'm not sure up they could wind up
being in the second round two weeks from
now when I get back from Indy and able
to continue to watch more tape but right
now to answer your question I've got
Berkeley at one take long parkland Penn
State running backs is that Quentin
Nelson it to the guard from Notre Dame
and I know guards don't go that high but
he's just too good to to move down and
I've got Sam darn old at three Josh
Rosen at four and the pass rusher
Bradley chugged the defensive end from
NC State at number five who's gonna have
the colonists to take a guard top five
do you think somebody's going to do that
oh it's cost there are some teams that
just absolutely will not it's just a
philosophy and but if you've got Andrew
Luck and Barclays gun right let's say
Barclays gone and and you're sitting
there at three the Colts are gonna have
a choice between okay do we get this kid
chub to chase down
deshaun Watson twice it twice a year to
chase down Mariota and the the maker of
stars and remover of tarps Blake bortles
I mean or do we get some week we got to
protect Andrew Luck in that shoulder
right I mean that's the decision that
culture can have when it comes it's
gonna be a tough decision because
they're both really good players and the
positional value tells you to draft up
the past roster because you can get
guards later typically if it's not the
Colts at three I think you you can look
at the Broncos if the Broncos handle
their quarterback position and free
agency let's say they certainly could
use an upgrade in the offensive line the
Jets it's the same thing if they handle
their their quarterback positions and
free agencies and they could go with
Nelson at six and then at seven the
Buccaneers have ever need as well so I
think somewhere in those first seven
picks is a really good shot that Quentin
Nelson comes off the board I I haven't
talked to a guy in the league that
doesn't think he's one of the top five
players in this draft and most guys have
them in the top three it's amazing right
the top terrors and you're you're right
a running back guard there's no way they
go one two and when it all comes down to
it exactly Todd I love always enjoy our
chats let's grab a beverage in in
Indianapolis I love that what I'm
looking forward to it and looking
forward to that your exhaustive coverage
I'm sure you've been grinding getting
ready oh yeah my exhaustive coverage
mike Mayock what do you think no no it's
funny it's great I really do look
forward to it every year and I
appreciate you in chiming in on the show
as much as you have thank you oh you
guys do a great job thanks but that's at
McShea thirteen the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience